В ефірі «heute journal» з
Гайнцом Вольфом і Марієттою Сломкою.
Добрий вечір.
За звичних часів це звичний процес,
що ставка податку на прибуток
нараховується з урахуванням інфляції,
щоб компенсувати горезвісну «холодну прогресію».
Нагадаємо: ціни зростають, працівники просять
підвищення заробітної плати
та отримують його.
Але потім настає пробудження:
через інфляцію люди з вищим доходом втрачають
купівельну спроможність,
але водночас отримують вищу ставку податку.
Такий собі холодний душ від «холодної прогресії».
Як зазначалося: Федеральне міністерство фінансів
намагається компенсувати цей ефект.
Це звичний процес,
а не особлива ідея міністра фінансів Лінднера.
Але в ці складні часи його податковий план
дуже політизований і суперечливий.
Інтерв'ю з міністром
відразу після репортажу Франка Бухвальда.
Літо в Берліні, міністр фінансів
проводить прес-конференцію в саду міністерства.
Лінднера непокоїть висока інфляція,
зростання цін на енергоносії.
Тому він пропонує закон про компенсацію інфляції.
Побут багатьох людей значно подорожчав.
Ми побоюємося зростання цін
на газ, енергію та продукти.
Водночас економічні перспективи
нашої країни стали непевними.
Ми також бачимо, що
прогнози щодо економічного зростання погіршились.
Лінднер планує виділити
близько десяти мільярдів євро допомоги,
а також підвищити розмір основного
неоподаткованого мінімуму,
збільшити розміри допомоги та пільг для дітей
та змінити податкові ставки.
Це пов'язано передусім із «холодною прогресією».
Вона виникає, якщо підвищення зарплати
відразу нівелюється податками.
Це особливо вражає низькі доходи.
Тут крива податків піднімається особливо різко.
Лінднер прагне трохи опустити її.
Найкориснішим це буде для середнього доходу.
Максимальна податкова ставка, що
перевищує 60 000 євро,
має залишитися незмінною.
Справедливість має бути на боці тих,
хто потребують солідарності.
Але не слід забувати й про тих,
хто віддає велику частину плодів своєї праці,
щоб підтримувати соціальну стабільність
у нашій країні.
Лідер SPD підтримує таке бачення
навіть тоді, коли дещо ще варто розглянути детальніше.
Це правильне рішення,
яким він показав, що ми хочемо взяти до рук та владнати
фінансові питання.
Але я наголошую, що для SPD
важливо зберегти фокус на людях
з низьким та середнім доходом,
які сильно постраждали від кризи
Це ми обговоримо детальніше з міністром фінансів.
Партнери з коаліції, «Зелені»,
скептично ставляться
до плану допомоги Лінднера.
Скільки грошей надходитиме?
Це 100 євро чи 500 євро?
Пропозиція,
яку зробив пан Лінднер,
має один напрямок, що означає, що більше я заробляю,
то більше грошей мені надійде наприкінці року.
І це несправедливо, на нашу думку.
Ліві в опозиції мають таку ж думку.
Це сумнівна пропозиція,
яка дурить людей.
Адже 70% населення отримають
від цієї «допомоги» дуже мало або взагалі нічого.
Лінднер не погоджується.
Його пропозиція допоможе 48 мільйонам людей
в Німеччині, каже міністр.
Але навіть у коаліції
йому доведеться багато кого переконувати.
А ось і він, Федеральний міністр фінансів.
Доброго вечора, пане Лінднере.
Добрий вечір, пані Сломка.
Політики бояться, що нас чекає гаряча осінь.
Багато людей із острахом
очікують рахунків за опалення.
Це справді критична ситуація.
Чи доречно зараз робити податкове впорядкування,
що надає більші переваги високому доходу?
Воно не надає переваги лише високому доходу.
Це можливість відмовитися від підвищення податків,
яке в іншому разі відбулося б приховано.
Але не будемо про все одразу.
Цього року ми зібрали два великих пакети допомоги.
До них належать комплексні одноразові виплати
для одержувачів Hartz IV.
Вони містять грант для одержувачів житлових субсидій,
ретроспективну податкову пільгу.
Наступного року буде проведено
велику реформу житлових пільг.
І ми покращимо життя людей
на рівні базового забезпечення
через надання нових соціальних виплат.
Але поговорімо про податкові ставки.
Так, я лише хотів показати це в контексті.
З одного боку, у нас є люди,
які потребують нашої солідарності.
А з іншого є ті,
хто складає трудове ядро країни,
вони платять багато податків та соціальних внесків.
І я хочу захистити їх від
автоматичного підвищення податків.
Якщо ми нічого не зробимо,
48 мільйонів німців будуть обтяжені
десятьма мільярдами євро інфляції.
Цьому необхідно запобігти.
Ну, загалом це не так багато.
Та вирішальне значення має розподільний ефект.
Якщо я мало заробляю, взагалі не плачу податків,
то взагалі не отримаю нічого з цього.
Але наразі саме такі люди
особливо страждають від інфляції.
Якщо подивитися на ставки,
люди з доходом до 25 000
отримують 213 євро допомоги.
А якщо людина заробляє багато,
100 000 євро і більше,
тоді отримає понад 670 євро допомоги.
Це ефект розподілу, який мають такі ставки.
Можливо, треба зменшити щось інше?
Людям з доходами 100 000 або 200 000 євро
насправді не потрібна допомога.
Їм вже і так «тепло».
Пані Сломка, ми подбаємо про житлові пільги
для людей, яким холодно.
Також є соціальні виплати для базового забезпечення.
Але йдеться про ні про що інше,
як про адаптацію нашої податкової
системи до інфляції.
Сильні плечі розширюються, щоб нести великий тягар.
Але так їм не доведеться нести ще більше.
І перед усім так ми подбаємо, щоб людям,
які дійсно не мають широких плечей,
раптом не довелося нести тягар високих податків
через інфляцію.
Це лише коригування інфляції.
Але ці 10 мільярдів здебільшого дістануться людям
з вищим доходом, суто з математичного погляду.
Суто з математичного погляду,
люди з вищими доходами також сплачують
основну частину податкових надходжень.
Звісно, ​​я не можу зробити так, щоб той,
хто не сплачує податки,
отримав якусь вигоду від податкового законодавства.
Йдеться про запобігання підвищенню розмірів податків.
Але сума, яку Ви назвали, не є правильною.
Я ввів певні обмеження.
Особа з річним доходом, що становить 62 тисячі євро,
більше не отримуватимуть фінансової допомоги,
тобто особа з доходом, що перевищує цю суму,
не отримуватиме додаткової вигоди.
Але 672 євро порівняно з 213 євро - все ж вигода?
Максимальний розмір фінансової допомоги
для однієї особи
з річним доходом, що становить 62 тисячі євро,
становить 479 євро.
Таким є обмеження.
Цей дохід приблизно в 1,5 рази
більше за розмір середнього доходу в Німеччині.
Особі з вищим доходом не буде надаватися
додаткова фінансова допомога,
і я не зменшуватиму у цьому разі податок на доходи.
Але розмір допомоги залишається незмінним.
Дозвольте я зазначу ще декілька важливих деталей?
За останні 10 років «холодна прогресія»
завжди компенсувалася.
Мій попередник, соціал-демократ,
навіть знизив податок на доходи для людей,
що отримували до 277 тисяч євро.
Як ліберальний міністр фінансів я пропоную
обмежити цей розмір у 62 тисячі євро.
Ось чому я вважаю, що це збалансовано
з соціального погляду.
І навпаки, варто зазначити,
що люди, які заробляють 3, 4, 5 тисяч євро,
самостійно оплачують рахунки за опалення,
страждають від інфляції,
але водночас сплачують
високі податки та соціальні внески,
будуть змушені ще більше платити,
якщо не буде змін у податковому законодавстві.
Я не думаю, що це справедливо.
Податкове законодавство має забезпечити
рівність між людьми,
які отримують допомогу через солідарність,
та людьми, які за все платять.
Але у разі з ПДВ Ви не заперечуєте проти того,
що держава, як Ви раніше зазначали,
«збагачується» через інфляцію.
Так, але ми дійсно використовуємо можливості,
наприклад одноразові виплати
як-от на оплату рахунків за енергоносії цього року,
надбавку на оплату рахунків за опалення,
щоб компенсувати це.
Щоб уникнути збагачення через інфляцію,
ми вже цього року зробили знижку на бензин,
щоб люди, які більше платять за бензин,
не поповнювали ще й державну скарбницю
через високий ПДВ.
Дехто може сказати,
що ця знижка на бензин це той «менталітет халявника»,
про який Ви говорили у зв'язку з квитком за 9 євро?
Я думаю, що ви можете побачити на заправці,
що ціни на бензин дуже високі,
особливо для тих, хто їздить на роботу
з передмістя в місто.
Я не вважав би справедливим,
якби люди платили за паливо
вищу ціну, яку встановили на світовому ринку,
а ця ціна обкладалася ще й ПДВ,
що поповнював би скарбничку міністра фінансів.
Деякі корпорації отримують вигоду від цього,
але Ви також не хочете вводити податок на надприбуток.
Такі компанії, як-от «BP» сьогодні мають назви
не «Bavarian Petroleum», а «British Petroleum»
або «Beyond Petroleum».
Їхні штаб-квартири розташовані не в Німеччині.
В нашій країні надприбутки,
тобто дуже високі прибутки,
мають виробники вакцин.
Високі прибутки також отримують виробники
вітрової електроенергії.
Але коли держава починає вирішувати,
який прибуток є прийнятним, а який ні,
це є справжнім свавіллям
з огляду на податкове законодавство.
І, до речі, це також завдає шкоди Німеччині
як майданчику для інновацій,
тому що ми хочемо мати інноваційні компанії,
як-от «BioNtech».
У Великої Британії з цим проблем немає,
Італії також успішно вдається
оминати цю проблему перерозподілу прибутку,
оподатковуючи обіг.
Якщо б ми захотіли, то давно вже це зробили.
Якщо розглянути це питання детальніше,
то можна помітити,
що в Італії великі проблеми зі стягненням податків.
А парламент Франції ухвалив рішення
проти стягнення податку на надприбутки саме з цих причин.
Пане Лінднере, дякую за інтерв'ю.
Дякую Вам.
У будь-якому разі
попереду нелегкі часи.
Підвищення цін на енергоносії
негативно вплине на багатьох.
Міністр економіки Німеччини вже кілька місяців
працює «комівояжером» у справах,
що пов'язані з імпортом газу.
Від Норвегії до Катару Роберт Габек
шукає потенційних постачальників.
А те, що на узбережжі Німеччини
такими шаленими темпами розбудовуються
ЗПГ-термінали для імпорту зрідженого газу,
ще півроку тому важко було б і уявити.
У цій ситуації, однак, варто поговорити про стан
й у власній країні,
а саме: про біогазові станції Німеччини,
де з кукурудзи та гною
роблять справжній скарб сьогодення.
Докладніше - Олівер Дойкер.
Майже ідеальна циркулярна економіка:
лише з гною та посліду виробляють
біологічний зріджений природний газ (ЗПГ),
яким можна заправляти вантажівки та автобуси.
Саме цим займається Куніберт Руе
на своїй біогазовій станції в Дархау,
що у Нижній Саксонії.
Раніше Руе був фермером, потім працював
будівельником біогазового устаткування.
Він розробив та продає пристрій,
який охолоджує біогаз до -151°C, а потім зріджує його.
Ми шукали рішення, що робити з біогазовими станціями
після закінчення строку дії державного фінансування
за Законом «Про відновлювані джерела енергії»,
що робити, коли станції працюють уже 20 років
і більше не отримуватимуть державного фінансування.
І тому ми обрали станції з вироблення біологічного ЗПГ,
яким можна заправляти великовантажний транспорт,
що також допоможе зменшити обсяги викидів вуглецю.
Очікується, що біогазова станція в Дархау,
яка виробляє ЗПГ
лише з відходів, як-от гною або посліду,
замінятиме приблизно 1,3 млн літрів дизельного палива за рік
та скоротить обсяги викидів CO2 на 7 тисяч тонн.
Якщо порівняти з тим, що минулого року
у транспортному секторі Німеччини
обсяг викидів CO2 становив 148 млн тонн, -
це лише крапля в морі.
Але навіть дрібничка може стати в нагоді,
і це лише початок.
Якщо ми переробимо весь гній та послід,
що отримаємо з сільськогосподарського сектору,
в біологічний ЗПГ,
то ми зможемо замінити 35% дизеля для вантажівок.
Для цього і створені наші біогазові станції,
для цього не потрібно будувати нові станції,
варто лише покращувати наявні.
Оператор АЗС «Q1» продаватиме біологічний ЗПГ,
що вироблятимуть в Дархау.
Це безпрограшна ситуація.
Мета нашої компанії - до 2035 року запропонувати
кліматично нейтральний продукт,
тому біологічний ЗПГ - це найшвидший спосіб
знизити обсяг викидів парникових газів
у транспортному секторі.
Екологи вважають, що виробництво ﻿із біогазу
ЗПГ для транспортного сектору -
погане рішення.
Коли охолоджують біогаз для отримання ЗПГ,
не можна уникнути втрат енергії.
З іншого боку, біогазові станції потрібні нам
для вироблення електроенергії.
А коли виробляють електроенергію,
одночасно виробляють і відпрацьоване тепло,
яке ми можемо застосовувати як джерело опалення,
наприклад за допомогою теплових мереж.
2020 року Німеччина імпортувала з Росії
56,3 млрд кубометрів природного газу.
Того ж року німецькі біогазові станції
виробили 15 млрд кубометрів газу.
Якби вони припинили свою роботу
через скасування державних виплат,
надійність енергозабезпечення в Німеччині
опинилася б під загрозою.
Залежність від російського газу,
через яку ми опинилися у такому скрутному становищі,
пов'язана також із розв'язаною Росією війною в Україні.
Продовжить Гайнц.
Після сильних вибухів на військовій базі
на анексованому Росією Кримському півострові
самопроголошена місцева влада оголосила там
надзвичайний стан.
За словами голови місцевої адміністрації,
загинула 1 особа, 14 отримали поранення.
Причина вибухів досі не зрозуміла.
Ситуація на окупованій Росією Запорізькій АЕС,
яка була обстріляна кілька днів тому,
також залишається складною.
Країни G7 закликали Росію
негайно повернути українській стороні
повний контроль над ЗАЕС
та попередили про ризик ядерної аварії.
Міністр оборони США Ллойд Остін
знову пообіцяв довгострокову підтримку Україні.
Сьогодні Остін здійснив візит у столицю Латвії Ригу
та також запевнив Латвію у солідарності США.
Вона є членом ЄС та НАТО з 2004 року.
Латвія межує з Росією та її союзницею Білоруссю.
Китай оголосив про завершення військових навчань
навколо Тайваню,
які тривали приблизно тиждень.
Китай розпочав військові навчання
після візиту американської політикині Ненсі Пелосі
до Тайваню.
Тайвань заявив, що такі візити є звичайними,
а Китай використав візит Пелосі
лише як привід для посилення погроз.
Сьогодні у землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія
завершилися літні канікули та
розпочалися заняття у школі.
Заразом розпочалися й дебати щодо захисних заходів
з метою запобігання поширенню COVID-19.
Союз педіатрів Німеччини
обстає проти обов'язкового носіння масок школярами
восени та взимку.
Міністерка освіти Німеччини Беттіна Штарк-Ватцінгер
повідомляє, що неможливим є закриття через коронавірус
шкіл у всій країні.
Якщо вчителі не можуть бути присутніми на занятті
через хворобу,
викладання має бути можливим
за допомогою цифрових засобів.
Лісові пожежі на південному заході Франції
вже загасили,
але 1 із 2 найбільших осередків полум'я спалахнув знову.
Понад 3800 осіб були змушені залишити свої будинки
з метою безпеки,
приблизно 6000 га землі вже вигоріло.
У лісистій місцевості південніше Бордо
пожежі загрожують 3 громадам.
Нова хвиля спеки ускладнює роботу із гасіння пожеж.
Очікується, що до неділі температура в районі
сягатиме 40°C.
Режим припинення вогню на Близькому Сході
залишається непевним,
навіть якщо Збройні сили Ізраїлю можуть вважати
свою триденну операцію у Секторі Гази
військовим успіхом.
Метою військових Ізраїлю була атака лідерів
та маршрутів постачань зброї
палестинського терористичного угруповання
«Ісламський джихад».
Певно, за мовчазного потурання ХАМАСу,
який підтримував раніше «Ісламський джихад»,
але сам не втручався у конфлікт.
За даними, всі ракети, які досягли Ізраїлю,
випустив «Ісламський джихад».
Як повідомляє ізраїльська сторона, одна з таких ракет
не долетіла до Ізраїлю
та вдарила по провулку у Газі.
Жахливі наслідки цього вибуху сьогодні потрапили
до заголовків газет у всьому світі.
А кількість жертв стає політичним питанням.
Докладніше з міста Газа - Андреас Кюнаст.
Під час поїздки через Джабалію,
через це переповнене біженцями місто
на півночі Сектора Гази,
ніщо не нагадує про ракети, про смерті,
про божевілля минулих вихідних,
поки ви раптом не опинитеся
перед траурним наметом,
який поставили сусіди в пам'ять
про померлих батька та п'ятьох синів.
Хлопці були такими ж завзятими, як і їхні друзі,
вони не мали шансів.
У суботу ввечері, відразу після настання темряви,
у провулку пролунав вибух, під час якого
загинуло п'ять людей, двох важко поранено.
Хлопчик грався, жартував, як і всі вони.
Дівчина була вдома
і мала вийти, щоб покликати брата на вечерю.
Дівчинку звуть Рахаф, їй 11 років,
вона навчається у шостому класі.
Коли ми зайшли до лікарняної палати,
там панувала тиша та неспокій.
Потім мати знімає ковдру.
Світ має це побачити.
Лікарі ампутували Рахаф обидві ноги та праву руку.
Коли ракета вибухнула,
батьки вибігли, кричали, шукали, плакали.
Ми знайшли її брата.
Він був весь у крові, але живим.
Ми дочекалися, поки приїде швидка допомога,
а потім продовжили пошуки Рахаф.
Через дві години ми знайшли її в лікарні,
без ніг та з однією рукою.
Ракета, яка була запущена в Джабалію
і яка понівечила Рахаф,
є найполітичнішою та найсуперечливішою
в недавньому конфлікті,
оскільки ніхто не підтверджує її запуску.
Угрупування «Ісламський джихад» звинувачує Ізраїль,
але Ізраїль публікує ось це відео,
яке має підтвердити,
що ракета була запущена в секторі Газа,
але випадково впала в густонаселеній Джабалії.
За 2 км від цього, на пів дня раніше,
ізраїльтяни зруйнували будинок Одай Шамллаха.
Це точно були вони, тому що
зателефонували заздалегідь.
У мене задзвонив мобільний:
«Привіт, Салам Алейкум, у тебе є дві хвилини,
щоб евакуювати всіх з будинку».
Це був чоловічий голос, номер - прихований.
Одай Шамллах разом зі своєю родиною
залишив будинок,
взяв з собою телефон і спостерігав,
як вибухає його будинок.
Він не знає причини.
Терористи, може сусіди?
Він не знав.
Питання провини у терорі та запуску ракет
роздирає Близький Схід на шматки.
Хто б це не був,
але минулої суботи в Джабалії він завдав
шкоди невинним.
Далі продовжить Гайнц Вольф.
Ми вже обговорили інфляцію в Німеччині в ефірі,
тому зараз про ситуацію в США.
За новими даними щодо інфляції, які були
оприлюднені сьогодні,
зростання цін було не таким високим, як очікувалося.
Франку Бетмане, яким буде розвиток подій далі?
Останні дані дають надію на те,
що ріст цін досяг піку.
Передусім знизилися ціни на енергоносії та паливо.
Падіння цін на американських АЗС
спостерігається вже протягом кількох тижнів.
Рівень інфляції все ще становить 8,5%,
порівняно з 9,1% в червні.
«Пік хвилі інфляції позаду», -
упевнений головний економіст
банку «Deka» Ульріх Катер.
Однак потрібно пройти довгий шлях,
щоб інфляція знову стала 2%.
Це стосується як Сполучених Штатів, так і Єврозони.
Особливо в нашій країні,
де привид інфляції досі лякає,
такі заходи, як знижка на пальне та
пільговий квиток за 9 євро,
полегшили життя громадян, але лише тимчасово.
Уже в жовтні навряд чи вдасться уникнути
подальшого зростання цін
через запланований збір на газ.
Однак сигнал з Америки прискорив роботу
фондових бірж.
Фондовий індекс Dax зріс на 1,2%,
промисловий індекс Доу-Джонса - на 1,4%.
За розрахунками інвесторів, якщо ціни
перестануть зростати настільки сильно,
Федеральній резервній системі США, можливо, більше
не доведеться вживати настільки рішучих контрзаходів.
Не викликає сумнівів і те,
що вона продовжить підвищувати ключові
відсоткові ставки.
Обговорюється тільки те,
наскільки масштабними будуть наступні кроки.
З нами був Франк Бетман. Дякую!
Більше громадських безкоштовних фонтанів
з питною водою в Німеччині.
Таким є законопроєкт федерального міністра охорони
довкілля Лемке,
який сьогодні ухвалив кабінет.
У майбутньому муніципалітети мають забезпечити
ще більше загальнодоступних фонтанів
у парках, пішохідних зонах та торгових центрах.
Фонтани мають стати
частиною запобіжних заходів від спеки.
А зараз про лотерею, номери якої Ви бачите на екрані.
10, 18, 22, 24, 26, 27. Суперномер - 2.
Більше виграшних номерів можна знайти на lotto.zdf.de
на ZDFtext, сторінка 557.
Не тільки Гамбурґ оплакує втрату Уве Зеелера.
«Наш Уве», той, кого так називав практично увесь народ,
багато чого у своєму житті зробив правильно.
Роблячи щось видатне,
можна здобути славу та захоплення,
але не автоматично таку прихильність.
Ті, хто його знав, кажуть,
що він був милою людиною з добрим характером.
Це також відчули ті, хто любив
і захоплювався ним лише здалеку як іконою
німецького футболу.
Сьогодні з ним попрощалося його місто Гамбурґ.
Там був і наш кореспондент Ральф Ціммерман
фон Зіфарт.
Після смерті його величезна бронзова стопа
на стадіоні «Фолькспаркштадіон»
остаточно стане місцем, де завжди збиратимуться люди.
«Наш Уве» житиме вічно, впевнені фанати.
Життя, яке не описує жодна книга.
Він виступав за справедливість, був справжнім,
був нашого з Гамбурґа.
Він залишився нормальною, простою людиною.
Він один з тих, хто завжди був поруч.
Справжній друг - «Наш Уве».
Сьогодні на стадіоні HSV зібралися не лише
знаменитості німецького футболу, Флік,Кан та Ко.
Канцлер також взяв участь в прощальній церемонії
з почесним громадянином Гамбурґа.
Помітно враженим був бургомістр цього міста,
яке Уве Зеелер не хотів покидати ні за які гроші на світі.
Ми всі хочемо висловити нашу щиру подяку сім'ї Зеелер,
тому що, звичайно, не завжди легко
мати такого відомого чоловіка і батька.
Це людина, яка була в центрі уваги громадськості
навіть у похилому віці,
яка була віддана спорту, своєму місту та своєму HSV.
Футбольний геній,
чиї голи в 1960-х роках і сьогодні є легендарними,
і якого ніколи не бентежили великі гроші,
як, наприклад, в італійському футболі.
І той, хто завжди присмачував свої переконання
дрібкою гумору.
Але ви не повірите мені, якщо я скажу вам зараз,
що тут є схованка з моїми грошима.
Гравці мають заробляти багато, але я думаю,
що ми мусимо бути обережними,
щоб не було перебільшень.
Це, мабуть, єдине, що я можу критикувати,
тому що футбол - це не тільки гроші.
На міжнародному рівні йому було відмовлено
у найвищому титулі.
Гол «Wembley 66» став його найбільшою поразкою
і, можливо, душевною силою,
тому це один з його фірмових знаків.
Найбільший титул не можна виграти взагалі,
його присуджують
люди, уболівальники, він йде від серця.
Говорячи прощальні слова,
він висловився від усіх вболівальників.
Я знаю, дорогий Уве, ти дивишся звідси вниз
і тримаєш руку над цим стадіоном, над Гамбурґом,
над HSV, над його вірними вболівальниками.
Кадри з перших років у збірній.
Варто згадати одну з його життєвих мудростей.
Я завжди казав, що якщо футболіст не знає,
куди подіти м'яч, то повинен бити його у ворота.
І тоді він робить все правильно.
Це був сумний день у Гамбурзі,
але й певною мірою щасливий.
День пам'яті того, хто ніколи не впадав у відчай.
Це був ефір «heute journal».
За мить буде ефір «Auslandsjournal»
з документальним фільмом про ситуацію в Афганістані.
Катрін Ейґендорф і Себастіян Ем провели там два тижні
і покажуть, наскільки угруповання «Талібан»
змінило країну.
Побачимось завтра. До побачення!
Доброго вечора! Поговоримо про погоду.
У Європі спостерігається сильна посуха.
У Німеччині теж випало занадто мало опадів:
в середньому - 103 л/км².
Метеорологічне літо триває від 1 червня
і завершиться в серпні, тож ми маємо ще кілька тижнів.
Для того, щоб побити рекорд, 130 л,
шанси, на жаль, непогані.
Все через те, що утворився антициклон.
До цього всього ще й сильна східна течія та циклон,
який принесе наступні хвилі спеки в Іспанію.
Вночі малохмарно, сухо,
але на півдні сильний вітер з східним потоком,
у горах - частково штормовий вітер.
Водночас температура 9°C біля підніжжя Альп,
і 18°C у районі Рейн-Майн.
Завтра буде сонячно та все ще сильний вітер на півдні,
наприклад, над Швабським Альбом,
на вершинах очікуються штормові пориви зі сходу.
Крім того, температура на південному заході
сягатиме 32°C.
Тут в нагоді стане вітер,
який полегшить відчуття температури.
На Балтійському морі очікується 24°C,
на Нижньому Рейні - 34°C.
Найближчими днями буде сонячно та спекотно, до 34°C,
на півдні Німеччини місцями грози зі спекою.
На інших територіях температура в неділю
підніметься до 35°C.
Гарного вечора.